back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
what's up broke good to see you - so I'm
just saying maybe this time since we
just used Mighty Max is it ok this time
if we do the old buzzers why don't we
put our thing up on the Instagram story
and let the fans decide you wants to use
the cool hip one that our boy Matty Mac
3000 made okay or should we use the
toys-r-us ones that feel likes okay and
hit them all and it lights up did that
lit up hit them oh thank you tied up
juice yes mine does let me see you light
up first let's do this ready yes we are
turn its on I did it break yeah but did
not I turned it on oh [ __ ] oh no hold on
dude see you're moving it all around Wow
well that's all I just needed one of
those it works once in a while like a
Russian dude there you go works once in
a while it's like a sec so you guys want
this hold on that's one of them and
that's mine or or how about this we'll
bring this out for the King and the
sting round specifically okay I
appreciate you compromise a man I
appreciate you I'm just high stress
right now dude
yeah finger stress yeah man a black box
around us you know yeah who knows what's
in there dude what if they crack that
open and uh yeah yeah the voices of
thousands of Malaysian people that were
on that plane you know 6000 people died
yeah dude look that up there at Kenya I
mean you can't even tell which one
Malaysia is basically just a place to go
if you want to crash a plane now it's
like it's as common as like like doing a
bungee jumping or something yeah it's
like the new or they caught Bermuda
Triangle yeah it is that's a new hip
triangle these days yeah a lot of people
if you're gonna push your wife off of a
cruise that used to be like a roux but
you would do that but now everybody's
doing it in Malaysia
what's next y'all yeah the Florida yeah
you head down to Tampa and start pushing
people off cruise ship dude what's the
next what's next you're gonna go out
there to st. Landry Parish and throw you
through your side piece out of a pirogue
sure you got a damn
go to [ __ ] Golden Corral and stuff
ribs in your wife's mouth and make her
disappear dude people people do yeah
people dude Wow we're gonna get this
episode man for CT flares up so bad ro I
want to check you into a center you
might be in a center right now I might
be man this is all just fake [ __ ] is
the gay tricks dude yeah and your
instead of pills you eat dicks full
buddy it could have been you spend time
with a guy doing something you like
painting that would be Jay yeah it would
be and that would be enough um to go
straight to sex yeah you're right dude
knock knock who's there an advertisement
man I'm hungry sometimes and you know
what times all the time dude me too you
want sushi at 9:00 p.m. maybe want a
breakfast burrito in the morning don't
sweat it post mates is your personal
food delivery grocery delivery whatever
you need up you what kind of service man
yeah your round do I know you want your
breath to smell like something good like
snacks or like cake or pie or sweets or
wine or coffee
yeah or anything post mates can do it
for you it's your personal food delivery
24 hours a day 365 days a year post
mates will bring you whatever you want
within an hour anything you're craving
you wake up in the middle of the night
you roll over to ask your spouse or
significant other to go get you
something from the store but they'll
they're not even there because they left
you months ago I post mates loves you
more yep doesn't even matter doesn't
matter for a limited time post mates is
given the king sting listeners $100 the
free delivery for the first seven days
start your free deliveries right now
download the app and use the code cats
that's K 80s 2019 that's code cats 2019
for $100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days when you download the
post mates app yup that's right that's
code K 80s to zero one nine for $100 a
free delivery credit for your first
seven days when you download that post
mates app get that app and get those get
those eats or snacks or anything time to
pay the bills man look I'll be honest
with you bro if you're like me or on
I'm being honest with you I'm just
saying this but you're like me you're
not always paying attention here banking
everything sometimes it's just zeroes
and negatives yeah give it up we're rich
so you might be I'm not
you look really rich though thank God
for Dave Oh Dave is the number one
budging app in America app because it
saves you from overdraft fee's tells you
about upcoming bills and can advance you
$75 from your next paycheck and no
interest who hooked you up Dave did ask
for Dave get the Dave out and for just
$1 per month
yeah it's 12 dollars a year which is way
less than an overdraft for you when you
think about it and you never have to pay
for an overdraft fee ever against Mike
dave has got your bag this could be you
know any Dave you want but dave has your
back he's gonna make sure you don't have
overdraft fee's gonna make sure you know
when bills are coming up and if time to
get tight yeah boy DAV Z gonna lend you
that soft 75 so you can get through the
week bucks humans an investment in ya
market guy makes so much money fees into
it you know it's good three million
people already use Dave Santo $1,000 a
year no word a fees that's why it's the
number one budgeting app in the App
Store go dude Dave calm slash cat says k
80s it really helps the show if you let
them know you heard it here so download
the app Dave and you never pay an
overdraft fee ever again it's immediate
savings go now Dave dot-com / K 80s and
be the boss of your financial comfort
well Dave's your boss well get that send
me five soft yeah but you're the manager
Dave is the boss though Dave's your boss
now yeah support the podcast how we
kicking this off little rip my drift
ya didn't see a stupid ass outfit today
that there it is very cool Oh fantastic
and
could you look any more like the Rat
King in this yeah like it doesn't even
get a shirt like that it's a hamster
shirt man
your grandma's saying this shirt where
do you get a shirt like dr. rue into
that shirt I got that shirt when I was
12 years old and I've slowly grown up
and eventually one day it'll be like a
little tankini if I keep getting taller
it's going a fortune cookie you know you
you look like you have anger man's when
you take it out on hamsters like I'm
hangry yeah you just slap hamsters
around yeah that's your therapy too
seriously though where do you get that
shirt you know most hurt no joke man I
got that when I was young they had them
somebody died in our area and they gave
that up and you know I was first to jump
on that piece man I love small ground
game and the second I got a chance at
that piece of just to be fully haberdash
in this piece of sweet rodentia and you
can see it if you look on the YouTube
right there in this shirt is for camp
out the front actually there's team All
Hands and actually I'm joking this shirt
is actually GPA does guinea pig
that's a guinea pig yeah due to a
different game now yeah cuz guinea pigs
can take the body shot take a nice liver
shot oh yeah this is not a liver shot
yeah dude hamsters is so small the liver
shots a brain shots
yeah you don't do that you're full his
fist hits em you know yeah but a G pig
they're more built like that Daniel calm
yet yeah they're like a little warthog
furry warthog you really unload on them
[ __ ] things there's a heavy bags of
rodents just [ __ ] hit him dude
they're beautiful yeah man sir there's a
little bit of rip my drip man I expect
you to wear this though you know like
don't you surprise me these days yeah I
don't know like I've night if someone
asked me where you found that sure I
could not tell you oh that's a Theo
shirt like he might have drew it himself
and looked away this I got a the Boy
Scout I earned it like tying knots or
some [ __ ] I don't know what they do
there yeah dude tying knots in your
mama's bedsheets dude you feel me
welcome to Nottingham Robin Hood is here
why are you in sweats why are you
tapping your sweats I love show we're
sweats for one reason one reason we go
to the strip club you trying to get that
free nut off what everyone knows that
bro dude I'll jerk off by myself some
we're not driving your Center to some
organize corporation to jerk off dude
I'd rather make an LLC and just come at
the house Papa you can come in the club
bro
and them sweat yeah you have to nut
sweat we wish sweats the only reason
well I think people word sweats on
planes mal ha nut these are action pants
you delinquent that makes sense no I
couldn't find my um I couldn't find my
wallet that's why I was looking for
other yet hamster food in your pockets
dude I'm looking for something I lost
you don't you know what someone looks
like when they're doing that you don't
know anything I don't you bring Brandon
up yeah see my [ __ ] sweet ass drippy
drip Bing break him fresh off the
[ __ ] met down there's that 1960s
football card for your dumb ass everyone
did that receivers quarterbacks that was
the poem back then
leave that snarled up rat nose I got
broke bro you look like why is my nose
like that keep zooming out of my nose I
need a goddamn nose job can you buy me
one Theo what is happening to my nose
wrong I'm buying me one first and second
of all dude zoom back out man you look
at you look like the guy waiting for the
mail at the get a gay bathhouse bro you
look like this is you look like a mate
like an all men's mailbox
you know what I'm saying well you come
dumpster no mail just mail oh yeah
they're putting that mailing you Big
Daddy huh okay you want this postman
yeah you want this - ounce package and
only deliver through the back yeah you
want these thick stamps big dog you want
that two-day delivery big dog yeah dude
you look like sprawl bunion dude like if
it's a sprawl out on some dudes bed in
place you vote like you're about to play
fish dinner with an old man can we go to
another service we have to play Viking
freeze dag naked no oh my oh what is Oh
is that I come fresh off the Met Gala
look at them brow look like you look
like you [ __ ] I can't met a bunch of
kids behind a behind in Abercrombie &
Fitch
bro you looking at the high schooler
that won't die bro how what grade are
you in
50th you got UK with a hamster sir bro
yeah cuz I look good in anything baby
because I'm the damn Rat King son and
when your mother dies and there's rats
running out of her house I'll be there
alright baby baby I'm gravy [ __ ] but
yeah man what are you even doing here
dude dude I'm just living what do you
want student-council bro you gotta
[ __ ] you look like a picnic like a
trick Nick dude like something that the
kid that a lot of men tender man will
eat snacks off of your back if you laid
on the ground in a park Oh like the
naked sushi girls
yeah just like naked giant sushi dude
yeah dude you look like a trick Nick
let's get into this episode man roasting
each other how about I want to launch a
new yeah right now a new segment a
little roast my host boy yes my host
these are the best comments from people
online yeah because I figure we do we've
been dishing it out man and it's time
for us to take a little bit of it do we
dish it out to each other into each
other with some peeps we called
somebody's aunt fat a couple times I
definitely know that cuz I've woken up
at the middle of the night and been like
did we call somebody's hanging I know I
regret making finally get the owl no I
don't that guy definitely seemed like he
knows something that we don't but I do
regret that guy remember the older man
or woman that had the AH look like they
was just one shoot on steroids a wallet
that was stretched up and like a do belt
on if you ask most Vegas yeah steroids
yeah yeah yeah actually we you know my
chocolate body yeah yeah grandma yeah
yeah you're right dude yeah that's life
bro yeah and the nut like grandma yeah
yeah don't have she gamma don't have not
at all yeah sure about that don't submit
pictures of Grandma Lee not some grand
Packers and we take it easy yeah yeah
you know who doesn't have nuts most
every grandma okay so every now and then
if one pops through with some newts bra
it's okay it was
what's up your grandma slides my DM with
her nuts hanging out I gotta say
something yeah I must spill a little
turtle soup because I'm [ __ ] shell
shocked when I see that [ __ ] right but
we wanted to hear from you guys a little
bit uh Derek where do we get these from
these are all fan submissions these are
all from the YouTube comments from the
Instagram comments these are all just
the comments for King in this thing okay
and it's it's the fans ripping into feel
and and I yes okay so I'm gonna read one
that's the one about me and I'm read one
about you let's do that yeah yeah let's
do that good with reading or you I can't
help what do you want to do this uh true
call your mom okay let's let's pretend
that you completed every word in that
sentence first I'll call your mom till
you're trying to read before you pass
out that's a game we play often in here
is her tendon burned and use all the
letters recently in a sentence second of
all I would like to read this one ha ha
I'm just proud of you can read bro yeah
oh my old jokes against you
how's that against me well that'll bring
in read way better than you dude dude
what if you put a bunch of words in
front of us dude they wouldn't know me
way better than they would know you know
yeah go ahead dude bro when you open up
a book a lot of the words run to the
back of the book cuz they're like oh
[ __ ] yeah you just read coloring books
are you talking here comes your mama to
show you pictures here comes this mumble
B if I just do it rode hit it dude okay
we're trying to get my dick ovary out on
you and your mom and Derek and Kat we
want you guys to decide in the end which
one is the best one of each and the
winner would be whose fans well they're
both our fans but who got roasted worse
would be the winner right okay who got
roasted worse yeah yes will be the
winner and then the best one from each
side roasting you or roasting me gets
maybe a king distinct shirt we'll figure
it out okay they get something maybe
they get a deep-fried hamster from you
yeah that's fine dude
well you can eat cheap Pig if you go to
pro you can eg pick on the street and
don't send me any images up but you can
do it and I'll say this right now that
Brendan looks like the water buffalo Joe
Rogan's buddy shot in Australia
I haven't seen that we smell like dead
water buffalo you definitely see like
this big animals that there's always
like some [ __ ] rich white guys shot a
little bit of blood yeah and sometimes
there's no bloody just poisoned it yeah
just choked it out this guy Emmanuel
Baron who sent that okay and that was
illest flu illest flu it was fluid that
would spray you know this guy says Theo
looks like a 90s troubled teen that
learns to express his aggression through
dance you're the one thing I can't get
enough did you sing him so bad alright
alright
Brendan who sent that one in a manual
beer and brewery told you his name broke
I sorry I forgot his name
Brendan looks like a Special Olympics
coach it got fired for shooting up them
Tisza myth picogram game Jamaican
bobsled team boys electric Juicy Juice
Brendan Kato's SOS out there in
blackface dude gotta get him Sport eat
up boy Golden Snitch by Bram to lose and
now it is from guest Stephano Briones so
that's straight out of Spain I guess
Brendan looks like a manager at a local
car audio store the place you go in and
there's always like a car alarm
no I help you with yeah he's a car
nobody can turn off the guy that's
trying to help you take care of that oh
yeah oh you want to hear some Nelly
that's all the guy has two whole time
he's got Jason Aldean you boys want to
hear that do [ __ ] now
I guess drop your tail feathers oh yeah
you have one of your trunk you Father
she's you hurting on the manager okay
and that was from no Draya no Draya
well there is Brendon looks like a
Puerto Rican third baseman that flexes
his ass cheeks for a whole three-hour
game and that one was from Drew ski
everyone do a whole episode of this yeah
what else we got get us into something
else man get us out dark holding magic
carpet ride
I think Brendan flexing his ass for
three hours yeah that guy deserves a
hamster that may be the best one who's
the guy's name called Drago make sure he
gets the [ __ ] uh ice cream sandwich
the hamster whatever the Fuji that's his
name drew ski Jew skee-ball and I had a
friend him through that diet I said just
remember that yes but what else we
getting into here buddy I will start it
with a little debate club little debate
club all right oh bring up bring on
bring on the black box it's not for
debate club is it a king of thing off
for no reason this first one is from
Tony and Luna
mmm Tony and I own a super cute kid oh
man this is Tony Luna Wisconsin
father-daughter combo gang gang playing
music in forever video
yeah kids super cool anyway for you oh
yeah a lot of cats argue me personally I
like the orange nice and citrusy taste
so good you know what do you like what's
that in your hand what do you like what
is it apples oranges
buzz buzz game game thanks for all you
do boys
buzz buzz cute kid man young lady man
super young man is gonna be the one at
that age that's a lady for that matter
and God will choose brother but I'll say
this your beautiful child there thank
you for sending in that end Tony and
Luna apples or oranges I'm an apple guy
myself man I keep it keep it original I
feel like orange is kind of an impostor
real juice eat a lot of work they're
kind of the crab legs of the fruit game
oh you really got a crack in them to get
to the sweet Center Apple ready to go
yeah snap on into it put a little peanut
butter on there if you want whatever you
want to do bring it in here buck up you
know what else you could do yeah in high
school pop a little hole make it a
little smoking device out of it smoke
law devil's dandruff out of it chippie
chippie huh yeah that was a nerf is
cocaine you delinquents not well from
bro really yeah dude Devils dandruff is
weed maybe I get confused talking with
that Brown frown dude you might have
[ __ ] hit a little bit too much dude
but Satan's lettuce you might be talking
about scenes [ __ ] uh
fun about drywall you might be talking
about crack cocaine how about that big
bird Herbie Oh baby
oh yeah dude I'm talking about that
brown frown he's just smoked down
Louisiana boys Browns hero was when we
was brown dude it wasn't always green
there was a time where we'd given up on
itself you want with oranges or what
I'll say this man I like an apple - an
apple you put you here up - an apple you
can hear it say come [ __ ] me big dog
right oh wait are you eating the green
apples you're eating the granny apple
the granny apple says that goes to
granny I'm come [ __ ] me granny apples
are a little too hard is there horse
thinking a green apple it remind you not
to do sex with senior citizens no that's
why they're like that granny apples it's
a whole thing dude and then grandmas got
together went hey let's dip these in
caramel so we've tricked everyone not me
not me you old [ __ ] GILF City bro not
me you wrinkly [ __ ] I stay with the red
bro give it up for red apples don't
[ __ ] touch me touch me dude I've
heard actually 52% said apples as well
really but I go with oranges as an adult
and orange is something a little bit
more exotic you know you can you start
to know when an orange is good when
you're a kid you're eating shitty
oranges they'll give you that shitty
orange for summer camp takes you 3 hours
to get into that [ __ ] it's it's shot in
your eye 902 all the cuts on your hand
preach bro you know a something then you
put it in the it got hot in the [ __ ]
in your lunchbox I didn't play any
sports growing up but I did and so in
Little League in the half times how do
we give us oranges I love how he
considers reading a sport that's the
funny thing about Brendon he's like oh
yeah
now this can be played with your mamma's
your head should have a whistle for it
it's like man big game today and he
opens it up it's to say is it weird
though they give you orange slices at
halftime that was the only snack a
thousand orange slices cool every now
and then do it and yeah and you they
would leave like that kind of growth on
your face like that white dude yeah
sticky icky bro but yeah peanut butter
on an apple I go apples all day oranges
are more for adults and stuff like that
or people that are from Italy or
something like that you see the little
Italian every now and then over the side
a summer camp
[ __ ] sharpening his shoes and busting
into an orange you know get your
tangerines off me bro apple all day
yeah up next is Eric from Newark this is
Eric my dick bro sorry that's an old
joke gun what's that buzz gangster well
I'm an Apple user man thanks Eric for
sending that in and thanks for the
switch up with the Newark Ohio a lot of
people went Jersey Ohio
I thought Jersey a lot of people in
Jersey out of the gate and I stood my
ground and waited to see where you were
from not me Bryce West Jersey
god bless the Midwest dude who the [ __ ]
doesn't have an apple in America only
Isis [ __ ] with droids cuz you can't
detect them always scumbags and dudes
cheat on their girls [ __ ] with the Droid
the flip phones because there's no cloud
yeah real gangsters [ __ ] with Apple side
piece City it's a new phone store coming
near you yeah communication for only for
you to keep in touch with your tribal
chicks you know what I'm saying
Cricket Wireless yeah not your chief
stris not your main squeeze we're
talking about them you know secondary
squirts you're talking about that Metro
[ __ ] what's the old metro pcs yeah
what is the right side piece for cricket
B people constantly shooting each other
for cricket phones always the flip phone
yeah remember that one phone there we go
chip chip the next was the next oh if I
kick no yellow you can go trip chirp and
you like walk you talk to your friends
you know what imma it was a cell phone
that you could walkie-talkie it was next
he'll know it was Nextel and I was like
it was a walkie-talkie you also
cellphone but charged if you just want
use the walkie-talkie yeah you can see
where my last friends on the football
team to chirp was dope dude no I'll say
this man first of all that look man
don't text and drive brother cuz you
sound like a guy that's gonna do that
you're out
asking which phone to use little -
enough and you're driving yeah simply
give Robin something big and heavy maybe
with some quikrete in the back so if you
fall asleep with the wheel dude other
people die you got to think about that
it's not just you dying he's that cargo
hitter yeah cargo bro character like a
remodeler bro you know you're that guy's
definitely to take out a family you know
be careful yeah keep the eyes on the
road is what we're telling it's never
just the parent that dies when there's
kids in the backseat so you got to
tighten up out there brother this got
dark good oh it did bad but I'll say I
think it's Apple man at Apple for now
dude until the revolution until you know
humans strike back against robots and
then at that time I think it'll be you
know just rumor and letter back to
people writing letters here's the
problem though with apple the Apple
[ __ ] workers commit suicide left and
right they commit suicide so much they
have to put a net around the [ __ ]
building hmm so I feel a little bad but
also gots to have my iPhone yeah it's
like diamonds I know they're blood
diamonds that's really fresh though yeah
so what do you do but here's the thing
it makes them look you know it means so
much more if somebody died like you know
I must killing everyone left and right
for them cars you know that yeah bet you
didn't know that yeah yet even know that
you just know that yeah enjoy an
electric [ __ ] car sixty-eight percent
went with iPhone as well yeah who's the
other percent this last one is from
Scott tisha WA white wagon is this a
character in Dances with Wolves okay
it's good getting her nickname right
it's curtisha white wagon oklahoma city
oklahoma state of american hey boss just
why why him Oklahoma City Oklahoma I'm
wondering what show was funnier give us
a button oh babe wait what is she saying
ren and stimpy
what's a better show beavis and
butt-head or Ren Stimpy oh you and I
look like beings about head if they grew
up and got their lives together in a
little bed don't we if you ever seen
beavis and butt-head I used to love that
show yeah I should go
yeah I remember that one day he buttered
a bud oh let's get a car yeah that's
them my judge bro yeah running stiffy
was a little filthy hey my son watch red
and Stimpy Ren Stimpy little filthy
filthy also look like Ren and Stimpy
don't we you look like a little
chihuahua like the big fat cat no I look
like the big fat cat
oh dude you have the nose as the cat but
daddy wise I'm the cat you're the little
chihuahua no you have the body of the
Chi actually my I have the body of the
you have the face of the cat we'll see
we're still what let's age a little more
and see how right let's not just chalk
it up yet you know but yeah I think the
first one what was the thing already a
stranger somebody helping somebody Ren
and Stimpy I think we're definitely more
exciting maybe some but head I used to
go steal all the beavers invited George
from Spencer's gifts out there at the
Slidell mall and I guess you feel from
time be be some but had jewelry oh wow a
lot of necklaces they had like a couple
of wristlets brace dude how big were
beef some butt head God a hammer in the
road they play like a rock through my
gap yeah they don't cut to me like one
would be jacking off to ac/dc I didn't
like Butthead I think like Beavis like
the blond head one better you did yeah
one was a [ __ ] idiot you know both
idiots I think you think no one of them
is smarter I think one time X you went
to school does it say any information
about their lives did you see the movie
beavis and butthead their movie film ooh
yeah their movie dude no did you see
Garbage Pail Kids the movie I think so
me - yeah eclectic art pail kids cards
oh yeah yeah oh yeah good dude
so good man gang don't touch me no
spilling you wrecked a little bit let's
move on man let's cut this thing is
making me a wreck sixty-eight percent
went with beavis and butt-head
yeah that's our that's our demo bro oh
yeah but Ren and Stimpy I felt like they
were just a little game changes weren't
they but no but they were just a
reinvention of Tom and Jerry in a lot of
ways you know there were like Mexican
Tom and Jerry's yeah yeah like real
x-rated Tom and Joe gonna [ __ ] hurt
you damn still be you eat
stampy you idiot yeah they're kind of
like us almost yeah yeah but you must
have been Stimpy then all right let's
hear more all right we're gonna go into
for my next that's what I'm ready to see
some bad Mia I see some all ties with
them I shoulda Masterchef's feel
exhausted yeah I know energy you like a
shark bit all the semen out of me
I feel like when I'm sucker fish got you
huh yeah and I just feel like I was the
sucker fish and I jerked off [ __ ] off I
feel very depleted it's like put when
you play apex or played that game mm-hmm
it's like a shoot it's like a
first-person shooter game but you have
people you don't know that are on your
team it's like when you just get shot
immediately you stop to lay there and
why you accidentally pressed the button
to watch the game still go on and that's
what you're going through cuz you jacked
off you're kind of in a simulation right
now he's just going through life yep
don't jack off dude I'm trying not to up
first we got uncle Elmo this is uncle
Elmo oh hell yeah low tip boy that belly
he lives with his mom the third titty
look at their glow tip look at the
calves on this [ __ ] quads down hotdog
brisket Milana calves thick Hawaiian
calf their brisket can you risk it that
thing is sticky icky and is that
house-arrest bracelet above the knee
which is sexy is that a house okay so at
least his uh his shorts aren't clean are
they little oil spills on the front
little ass cheeks out the back now those
are jean shorts those were jeans that he
decides to hot out and cut the legs off
[ __ ] yeah cuz he's a risk-taker
[ __ ] yeah his NASCAR family I bet my
life on it good boy I would inject those
calves with some seasoning and cook them
[ __ ] dude that's all those I'm so two
ribeyes sitting uh [ __ ] some femurs
brought low peon tubes Roni can [ __ ]
just gestating in my belly those things
look so damn good can you zoom out on so
we can see his face which is his face
for uncle Elmo Uncle Mo sipping uh is
that a Coke Zero is that alcohol adult
beverage no he's a koozie we talkin cool
Susi's bro that's when you know that's
when you know life is good
oh you got koozies you got thick calves
and a [ __ ] not much chest hair this
guy is a damn dime piece oh wow
this guy is definitely kind of guy
you'll meet on a service road it's kind
of guy who [ __ ] right off of a service
road near the Interstate
yeah King lot lizard see have a giant
hat on he's got a NASCAR I [ __ ] know
that's a Tim Tebow had in it nope that's
NASCAR it he has the stand lined here
the picture was taken at Talladega oh
dang sure call it bro
Ricky Bobby way too much first 48 Ricky
Bobby
this dude looks like Bobby Ricky Bobby
let's see the double Bobby's from one
Ricky dude Bobby Ricky Bobby be Harvey
son be right back with the [ __ ] dude
be right back without my [ __ ] shirt
Wow
I like that I like the swag of them just
having the the vest oh yeah that's that
redneck NASCAR swag do you dig that
would depend what state you're in
oh but I bet his skin smells like fresh
diesel bro yeah skin smells like button
motor oil you know yes I smells like
[ __ ] a turkey leg at Nazca beautiful
man beautiful aunt flump my aunt is out
of this area beautiful guy Elmo want my
uncle shut up - Elmo dude yeah
up next we got aunt and Madeline this is
aunt Madeline well goddamn Madeline
apparently your phone's on low battery
and you in the bathroom getting ready
charging it up on let's see how the
panties roll up a little bit oh it's
just counter I can't see it all that
well she she's a lot going on in the
counter she'll see going out took a
picture for a man before she went out or
someone she's in - that's what's going
on here could you not send this to a
friend your friends won't give up [ __ ]
let's flop mom what did they say about
the information any information with
endurance she likes playing guitar
making people laugh and she loves dudes
with mullets hmm she has the same
birthday as a theodore von is seeing him
at the brea improv in august
oh [ __ ] girl on there as well don't hold
it don't let me yourself to just the
modeling about me Brandon
she seemed like a nice lady she's Pisces
is that kalila though I'm wondering it
does look like Bobby Lee's girl and
whose is often she often flirts with me
when I'm on their show this is awkward
fer to slide into our show like this cuz
Bobby's probably gonna see it really
when's he gonna see it dude he's awake
for 40 minutes a day he's a koala bear
yeah dude sleeps 90 hours oh he's our
call he's always just he's you just
smelled the eucalyptus on his breath
dude that guy and I caught him
eucalyptus and dudn't ended up with this
lady that could happen Bobby wake up
Bobby the long nap Lee baby long nap
short [ __ ] they call him dude
do you know I'm not mad this auntie and
she's also you feelin my boy over here
so gang gang girl
buzz buzz young lady thanks see what I
can do though thank you for reaching out
yeah I'll see what I can do I listen
alright if you asked I'll do it I'll
play a love matchmaker I'll do that I'll
be your [ __ ] what's the name Chris
hand any honor we host the show who
hosts the bachelor no it's Benny I'll be
your Chris Hanson Chris Harrison no
Chris Hanson
I'll go like this come on in take a seat
why do you have my cards lemonade in
your car yeah Theo came in drink what
are you doing
what do you weigh of a batch of we have
a [ __ ] full batch of hamsters he has
his own what are you doing what are you
doing we have sweats what are you doing
with your sweats there what did a bunch
of hamster teeth made up necklace he
didn't like that [ __ ] this [ __ ] he likes
what do you have a picture of a
shirtless Dustin Poirier here he has
that here he has that girl Jesus Christ
man why do you have a bag full of warm
condoms because you left them on the
windshield they were sitting in the
direct Sun okay okay let me yeah now I'm
gonna read the some of your text to this
thirteen year old I want to jack you off
all night long did you say that they
like no I don't mean jack their penis
off yeah I mean the controller the video
game we're playing yeah anyways I'll see
what I can do for you girl we'll see
well but I will do that for you too but
only
no her Brendon she sent a picture I know
I'm gonna be your Wonderwall I'm gonna
be the filter that she has to get
through well I'll be your white Walker I
will do that for you no use in this
journey of love I will be your White
Walkers what yeah I'm gonna protect you
from from the crazies dude no dude
you're bromius handsome your bro me oh
and I'm fully yet bro okay that's the
truth dude and I ain't fallin for New
Year [ __ ] ah dude I'm gonna take
care of this for you hey-oh
first of all burns kind of guy when he
winks he has to obey he has to open his
mouth pop look at me keep your mouth
closed when you wank you creep you look
like you're in a coma and they ask you a
question you're trying to answer it
that's how you look you don't know how
to wink at people do you supposed to
wink like this where's your whole body
go with it doing cuz it's a it's a sign
of appreciation dude all I'm saying if
you are trying to meet a nice young lady
I will be that filter I will be that
love net for you that they have to get
through to get to my friend Theo yay
if you're a filter bro it's Rio de
Janeiro all right I'll do that Bri
owdacious we're here I'll do that nope
you're the [ __ ] not a filter dude the
last thing is I'll be your Klondike bar
oh dude I would rather freeze to death
somewhere dude I'll be your Chris Hansen
know what else we got there we got a
little relationship advice things
somebody advised me how to get out of
this damn relationship first we got
Trish from Utah Oh
yeah Salt Lick red iguana jawline
damages a seal beautiful rescue the dog
turtle shirts so I have been single now
for three years I don't have any kids
jump into a marriage right away or they
want zero commitment at all yeah they're
trying make questions he used only call
listeners
good quality single men look no further
go what you think I love you guys thank
you so much love you hey again I will be
this for you it seems like she's looking
for a husband and she's directing it
toward you again that's what's going she
didn't mention my name she's asking for
advice in her own natural habitat which
is Utah which is a different altitude
than where we are you yeah yeah you
right you right it's probably tough
pickings out in Salt Lake City
everyone's Mormon everyone's gonna have
multiple wives I don't if that's a
stereotype but I've been there look I
think that the thing is is you gotta be
out in places you got to be on street
corners but not in a not in a sexual way
you gotta be out there with a coffee be
out there drop a drop you know drop a
couple day miles playing pogs with your
friend here yeah playing pause what dude
okay you know I can't I just give her
some advice without you [ __ ] on my
idea
dude play pogs you don't hear dude she
bleep logs she's not playing Pete blue
eyes she's also you were 76 years old
she probably hanging out in the gym too
much that's problem here's your problem
you're eating too much beef jerky and
protein shakes go get a real meal yeah
or what I say is get out there you got
them rapunzel hairs growing out longer
and hanging off the balcony see if you
got a fella that climbs up for a [ __ ]
miller of Michelob Ultra you know what
I'm saying you get you a nice little
blonde roast and sit out front and some
daisy dukes see what comes your way you
see what you catch and your little web
of lies
drop something and see if some man help
you out with it
yeah and ask a man straight up are you
just looking for some sexual are you
looking for some you know love
sentimental action you know ask him
they'll be straight up yeah you got them
blue eyes then baby blues got lips nice
lips you got a chiseled jaw
you look like Thor if he's in female oh
yeah which is a good thing my friend
deals the looking he's alike and and
listen girl for you I'll do that Oh
every time you win dude I feel like a
someone's seen as someone's grandparent
that they really really loved I you have
these things how can you treat me like
this man because I wish I had a friend
like me someone should the way you treat
these women that Colin here telling this
lady to go play pogs out in the street
by the traffic
first of all Denver has that insane bus
that goes down the middle of the [ __ ]
sidewalk for no reason yeah about see of
16th Street my friend dad saw a lady
diet yeah no [ __ ] old lady dies everyday
there okay I'm so fast in the middle of
the [ __ ] run yeah they don't even put
any inkling no clue no sign that hey you
could you're about to die dude and
people die all the time trying to buy a
hat or a chapstick dude so where should
this lady go to meet a guy cuz I'll say
she's at the gym maybe she's [ __ ] too
many meatheads so that's good I'm gonna
work mix it up girl go go salsa dancing
which I'm sure all the white people in
you taller and foaming at the mouth to
do I'm gonna say this you probably you
seem like a confident woman I'll say
that you obviously you have that you're
you have some attractive looks and so
that's gonna be something that men are
gonna notice you may not be recognizing
that men are approaching you you may be
being too hard and not putting and not
giving out a vibe that you're
approachable you can't be too cool for
school and meet a cool guy I really
believe that you beat you act too cool
for school
you're gonna meet guys that are too cool
for to cool for you that's what you're
gonna meet Jesus I'm too today Junior
yeah
sorry good not all of us went to 30
grades okay
yeah it's called college yeah it takes a
while to get there it's easy to do sixth
grade four times
okay accent's dude yeah I think her
thing is guys are probably intimidated
up her because a smart dime piece works
out of time well as a [ __ ]
together who knows [ __ ] together she's
asking us for help yeah which means
she's obviously very smart does it I
think so
look at her dime piece you know she was
like push Prince Charming but princess
you have a [ __ ] gun behind her back
you don't know what she's like my I'm a
dick I don't trust in the internet but
here's what I'm saying good luck lady
here's how you meet a man go out there
take something drop it on the ground see
if a man help you get it slide it in a
bunch of DMC who gets back to you know
people are gonna get back to ya you know
go out there drop us something nice out
there a necklace or something no this
way you do make a bunch of grilled
cheese go on the corner see who grabs it
and offers or split half with you yeah
you go that's thinking bro yeah dress up
it like a homeless guy and see if
somebody will try to dress up like a
clown to someone oh [ __ ] yeah we got
cold bring my [ __ ] device out where's
your frickin you [ __ ] hater my boy
Mickey Mac made this Pandora your boy
you never even DM damn like I didn't
think I'd do I did do they give him a
video and a dick pic did you know I
didn't I did okay called my bluff huh we
got a first up this is Alex from
Connecticut don't believe it
Alex from Connecticut now I'm telling
you man pinging this thing is the dopest
pocket oh hey guys oh I didn't see you
there buzz buzz Gang Gang buzz buzz I'm
King they're singing for you yes sir
what do you think of rugby full-contact
less concussions than the NFL not true
less concussions in football not true
but full-contact men hit men women
hitting women all brutal all the time
but safer mm-hmm rugby kangaroos think
this thing on yeah it's basically
rugby's like New Jersey in the 80s
basically you know you talk about a mosh
pit but with a referee
what rugby is what's a mosh pit look
shoutout MO roommate Kevin just playing
gwgw the rugby team and they weren't
that great but one of my friends also
played on Berkeley's rugby team
they have heard the boys best program
all white boys all white boys some
Tongans they got supermodels playing on
the [ __ ] team dude and they run the
show until you down New Zealand the New
Zealand says hold my beer and this is
our sport American [ __ ] and beat the
[ __ ] out of us that's how it goes man
yeah I think rugby hopefully it'll gain
some ground I mean I think they're still
waiting for soccer to gain some ground
but if rugby I don't know how he gained
more ground in the US but I agree it's
not being ground already here's the
thing we used to play a game called
smear the queer yeah now that this was
in the 90s so when we get mad at me this
early 90s yeah that's what the kids call
I didn't develop game it's called smear
the queer you throw the ball up and then
who would get whoever get it everyone
would tackle that's rugby bro yeah we
all grew up playing rugby they just made
it all fancy got a ref put jerseys on
certain people got teams yeah well smear
the queer bro yeah I don't want to go
professional and smear the queer yeah
they put America yeah they put off
what's his name in the stands whose
yells buddy from Easter Island what was
that guy's name South Africa you know
I'm talking about the black guy nothing
I mean not Hussein Bolton no not Hussein
Bolton
he's someone who helped free a nation
you delinquent apartheid nothing I've
ever yeah they put Nelson Mandela on the
stands and they try to get already fired
up in the movie with Matt Damon's and
I'll tell you this I love good good
guess and I love rugby dude I think
rugby it's cool sport it brings people
together it's safer I think it's gonna
start to pick up ground because the NFL
is turning into kind of a [ __ ] it's
getting a little soft it'll pick up
everywhere but america whatever he
picked up here yeah that could be true
but it's over it's a real sport I think
you got more young people playing at
these days I don't think so I think
you're off on that I think I think
internationally that rugby is killing it
but in America we call it freeze tag bro
yeah we used to play smear to clear -
and we had a gay dude in our
neighborhood named Thicke Roy and he
would catch the ball he was I'm a sexual
but was he good he's Nicoya huh and
couldn't like tackle oh dude he was good
bro yeah see that's where the game
probably been even loved it dude he
would like holder he would like while
you were true he was big he would hold
your hand while you're trying to tackle
that dude and then he'd someone's he'd
tackle you it'll pop ya like what the
[ __ ] is going on saw the game started
smear the queer it's just one big tough
queer dude yeah
you know everyone it's Apple and their
kings a lot of the rugby yep and that's
Robert Baratheon shout out to rugby dude
I'm gonna kick it because I actually
appreciate the sport internationally I'm
in America some [ __ ] kind of like
our soccer here international dope here
um I'm gonna I support it as well next
up next this is from Robert from Florida
oh my god this is Rob
Bobby bear this guy looks like my
brother Cory no Robert you're fired
[Music]
[Laughter]
buzz buzz I'm sure he's taking a few
[ __ ] water buffalos down and then
pools thank ya you go nice cougar in the
backyard in the middle of summer shot
you a nice ice tea maybe it's spiked
with some next you know your balls deep
in that shallow end and this old lady
yeah I've seen a thousand times prettier
brother that's the Lord's work you're
doing that pal does I'm not a fan of the
sex in the waters not my thing
do I look like a frog to you I'm not I
like it raw dude but not in pools
narleen [ __ ] pools I can't feel
anything
it's like it desensitizes my dick yeah I
don't feel anything as well [ __ ] the the
jet in the hot tub I can't feel anything
what or just not [ __ ] anything well
Donna Shane if you're gonna do it it's
all through your body
you're busting nuts and hot tub dude I
have jerked off in a hot tub yes well
that's gonna be my pool bro yeah us like
you can't come to my pool okay it's not
allowed bro I don't want to go out there
all right what I'm trying to say is this
dude I think having sex in a pool it's
almost it's like trying to [ __ ] and like
be in the Navy at the same time or be a
merchant marine I can't do it any I'm
not strong enough man somebody they can
[ __ ] in the water dude immediately
should qualify for buds and be able to
go into being potential Navy it's called
Aquaman yeah not everybody can do it
dude no it's not for everyone
yeah I think my dicks a little more
grass
fighty people that might have more of a
slick dick could do it my dicks more of
a Ranger type I can [ __ ] in the
mountains high elevation bring it on
mile-high club member
water not my thing yeah I'm not a frog
as they call it yeah I'm not gonna be
seals frogs
that's code this lingo yeah I'm not that
amphibian um but thank you man and good
luck man thanks for keeping the the
pools clean I like a clean pool nothing
to clean pool stay out of my pool King
pool but sting their sex and balls last
ones from you like [ __ ] pools yeah
Derek what's going on no it's just water
do I look like a fish I'll [ __ ] a faucet
if I were that stru Barracuda yeah I'll
jerk off in Hawaii you know I'm saying
yeah I'll go down to Florida and jerk
off in the hotel right yeah I want that
much moisture in the air
Florida's crazy dude jumping to Bay just
slip right off the side of it everything
is just so much moisture down there you
shake somebody's hand you can't even get
it it's weird then it's like you're just
a sauna together yeah
let's go to cat what do you think about
pool sex cat hot tub or pool cat litter
is a terrible idea the water washes away
all natural lubrication so it just like
it's drug and that a good time to me
other than the girl you got all them
weird ingredients chemicals going on
chlorine chlorine in your [ __ ] come
on bro next science last one is from Ben
link from Durham it's been linked from
Durham BL what he's a teacher
question for King it first sting it my
students and I included wear Crocs on
Friday so kids with Crocs acceptable
adults with Crocs
I need the experts opinion can't get a
sting it maybe maybe go grab a cup of
coffee with Doc fashion it for a second
so with Crocs it's absolutely no no
really not as a male you can't do it why
special run kids
well adult male he's talking yeah you
can't do it dude you absolutely cannot
do it and why not it's Crocs just ain't
the thing man it's like wearing
comes with tofu and a Tesla you just
can't do it yeah you can't do it though
but what if you want to know if water is
warm or not and you still want to keep a
shoe on buy some aqua Sox Morocco Sox
begin yeah I guess you can tell an aqua
Sox but whit but you could use a crock
to what you want to put sand in your
shoe without taking your shoe off wear a
sandal I thought we'd go the entire
history of this show without you
outsmarting me but yeah I must say no on
the Crocs if I see an adult in Crocs I
know immediately then I can sell him a
used car
I see the Dalton Crocs I know either
touch his kids or he's getting no [ __ ]
God dude the guy's a teacher could you
thought of any other idea and first of
all he's a teacher with tats hanging out
I'm sure he's pretty loosey-goosey with
the kids he's the guy that puts on
movies for the kids all right kids watch
Malcolm X for the 17th time yeah we're
gonna watch Vietnam scenes we're bond
Schindler's List for 17th times we don't
put on Schindler's List it's about a
guys who's trying to tell everybody the
Holocaust is gonna happen but he just
stutters so bad he can't and so it ends
up happening that's crazy huh and
there's a lot of rumors about that yeah
there are let's hear something else
Derek get me out of this place the [ __ ]
out of here dude we did it man don't
touch me you don't [ __ ] touch me
after Australia down under brah
yeah I'm off to Australia might be
careful man dude yeah things that can
kill you down there yeah and I this is
this nah people don't know those
qualities have herpes she's really oh do
they have chlamydia
they've chlamydia yeah every koala does
so if you get it tell your girl you got
it from the koalas oh that's a good idea
huh so I got to go to one of those parks
and get some pictures of me with yeah
that's what I did went right off the
plane [ __ ] with some koalas petted
kangaroos like we good that's a
blackbelt tip for you is it yeah dude
enjoy it down there my man yeah I'm
excited man I'm excited to get down
there and get some sunshine down there
you know man have fun dude have fun for
us thanks man I will dude and I'll be
down there I'll definitely be wearing
toshing bro shirt when I'm down there
you know and is there a lot of violence
down there zero violence oh wow
zero [ __ ] shootings no guns ton of
Asians I'm just not that there's a
problem that's their holiday though is
that true cat let's get that cultural
corner here yeah because Japan's not far
away
Asia is not that far we think about it I
am not sure what that side of the world
does I've been there I'm telling you man
today I got off the plane I was like oh
[ __ ] there's I didn't expect so many
Asians I know there's a problem with it
but like yeah this is where they go for
holiday yeah so don't be alarmed it's
all good baby
don't they care you have some koalas
slap some crocodiles yeah yeah get some
rest
I'm exhausted I'm good take a nap right
now think I want to thank everybody so
much for supporting King in the sting
yes all right is this gonna be our last
one in this studio
are we moving the new station if I know
correctly this I think we when we come
back we're in the news tube you know Jim
yeah well it's been real and it's been
fun it's been real it's been fun and
it's been real fun uh Derek Kat thank
you guys
love you guys yeah thank everybody well
the fans again you guys make the show so
you guys sending submissions and yeah
yeah we can't do the show unless you
submit so much good stuff where's that
guy who usually makes the videos where
he's like burning pigs and stuff I get
shooting guns you know that dude oh I
know that creature thank me too I think
he's probably the rest I think you
robbed the bank did he he look like a
bank robber alone be safe dude trap I'll
be in Cleveland yeah I think you're
being Australia being Cleveland yeah
dude okay all right I'm out
[Music]
the king
[Music]